[Musique]
on m'appelle haut
je suis l'ange mans
ni trottoir avec les vagues
moi je verrai
il
mende et revêtent les ans
mon ma mère
j contre actuellement
et merci
abello
ce mode aubergines ne vous fait pas peur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
bon alors mesdames mesdemoiselles nous
allons étudier aujourd'hui la manière de
rédiger une contravention
puisque vous aurez l'occasion au cours
de votre service d'en dresser de
nombreuses noyau de se lier b vous avez
ici le le correspond à la date du jour
où l'infraction a été commise
je vous indiquerai ici l'heure à
laquelle vous avez remarqué de la
contravention
à ce sujet je vous mets en garde contre
peut-être des mauvaises habitudes que
vous allez prix surtout en ce qui
concerne les dons passer le cap de midi
il ne fera pas marquer ici
1h30 lorsqu'il sera 13h30 il faut donc
dès maintenant habitués à employer les
heures administrative ceci afin d'éviter
certaines petites entourloupettes que
des usagers de la voie publique ont
coutume de faire
[Musique]
vous mademoiselle s cette idée d'exercer
une puissance qui vous a attiré dans
cette voie qu'est ce que c'est je suis
attiré par ce que j'aime travailler dans
le public et aux volontaires
quand j'ai rencontré des aubergines pour
dire où en interne et bien j'étais
attirée quand même c'est pas par
l'uniforme déjà maman fasse je trouve
que ce qu'elles font est agréable d'une
part parce que quand on a des enfants à
s'occuper
on peut déjà avoir eu par exemple une
matinée de travail et leur accorder une
après midi je pense pas je serais assez
verlan c'est à dire qu'il ne battrait
pas d'europe le record des papillons
nous n'avait pas l'intention de vous
entendre
qu'est ce que vous faites si un
automobiliste vous fait la cour s est
vous dire non soyez gentils venez
prendre un verre ne mettait pas de
papillons
[Musique]
on
coc
bonjour mesdames en ce qui concerne les
infractions en matière de stationnement
payant celle ci commence à partir du
moment où les lui qui se trouve derrière
arrive au point zéro
naturellement il n'est pas question que
vous commenciez à dresser final à une
contravention
à partir de ce moment là il faut quand
même laissé un certain laps de temps
avant de rédiger votre contravention ce
laps de temps vous est fixé en principe
à 10 minutes
donc c'est à partir de la dixième minute
que vous rédigerez votre contravention
il faudra mettre une somme de 4 francs 4
ans qui correspond à deux heures de
stationnement qui le maximum dans la
zone at rationnement payant ces
appareils sont souvent soumis à des
déprédations
c'est à dire que l'on n'est introduit
soit des morceaux de chewing gum soit
des trombones afin de les rendre
inutilisables
il ya quand même une chose pourquoi les
personnes qui commettent une infraction
ne veulent pas accepter qu'on établit
sans fin du mois une contravention on
landresse cette contravention alors que
ont commis la faute
ça sort à la hauteur des trois quarts
francophones ne veulent pas ne suis ni
même une explication si une personne à
qui on met une contravention reste trop
longtemps c'est donc qu'elle gêne
quelqu'un d'autre évidemment les
automobilistes ne l'entendent pas comme
ça on reçoit les injures on reçoit tout
mais en fait pour moi personnellement la
base de la contravention c'est rendre
service à quelqu'un d'autre en a connu
un je ne sais pas elle évoque ses tenues
on n'est pas accepté je ne manque pas
évidemment on est bonne c'est les aider
que c'est nous qui sommes en face au
rusé si on est accepté ou si on n'y est
pas on est là pour rendre service à une
certaine catégorie de gens peut-être dix
mois le constat 6 à manger que ça parce
que ça vous dit on est injurieux et on
est une grille mais quelle sera votre
réaction personnelle - personnel je
serais à juriez en pensant que je rends
quand même service à quelqu'un oui votre
attitude alors pour précisément bien
gardé mon cas
ah la la
on a fait
on
[Musique]